diaz
pimento
what's up what's up with you
i need you to sign this report okay
i'll sign your report
what the hell
careful
the ink's still wet maybe this will help
okay they got to knock that off loosen
up sarge
summer love baby it's march man shut up
kick it out losers
guess who got their dealer nice had it
go down chasing through a subway tunnel
back up through a storm drain adrian and
i got engaged and then we busted him
with half a kilo of coke in his sock
what did you just say it was in his sock
these dummies they never think we're
gonna check their socks no before that
weirdo the getting engaged part oh yeah
we got engaged engaged engaged yeah as
in to be wet yeah seriously yeah amazing
we want deets tell us everything i don't
want to toot my own horn or anything but
it was
super romantic
you follow i'll cut them off in the
alley okay wait you want to get married
i have an announcement to make when i
was in that uzbek prison choking on my
own blood because my face was being
beaten in i realized
life is funny that's what you realized
and it's short we're picking up where we
left off when adrian went into hiding
we're getting married tomorrow
tomorrow that's real quick thank you
sarge
and we want it to be beautiful and lush
and romantic just like a nancy meyers
movie she's our favorite director oh i
love you've got mail that's nora ephron
you idiot i know i gotta hand it to you
captain that was some ceremony it wasn't
difficult i simply said what i wish had
been said when kevin and i got married
oh well then i never would have heard
your hilarious efficient official quip
you're right i regret nothing
but all this does make me think i might
enjoy a more
festive expression of our commitment to
one another are you suggesting we hold
an honest-to-goodness wedding
nothing too elaborate we're not the
kardashian west's after all
they are a musician and a celebrity
personality who recently wedded yes yes
i know they were answers on jeopardy i
think you mean questions
[Laughter]
you guys are fun
yeah i stole those coins can't believe
you bought that whole story they
underestimated you randy just as they
underestimated raymond holt uh you guys
haven't been that great to me either
well you got to teach people how you
want to be treated randy dr phil r.i.p
the point is captain holt solved the
case when no one else could he's
actually been stealing from these
archives for years you've been asleep at
the wheel alistair you're an
embarrassment really well at least i've
never confused scent augustine with bow
etheus oh who gives a rat's ass about
boethius wesley what are you doing kevin
i'm creating a kerfuffle oh damn sure my
husband is a hot piece of ass but he is
so much more than just that raymond holt
is as smart as anyone in this department
but he chooses to use his intelligence
to make our city a better place
one day i hope to live up to the
standard you set you make me want to
have
a wetter brain
oh kevin
[Music]
y'all are hella specific it's a
policeman just like you papa this is the
coolest present ever i'm detective papa
and i'm going to go to the farmer's
market i hope they have aged cuda
my god i'm melting i'm literally turning
into a puddle genevieve hold me i got
you babe
oh honey that flat ass is perched right
on top of my ute i'm gonna pretend not
if that was said for the sake of the
child
jakey
hey
are you guys wearing one scarf yep
charles forgot his this morning it's
actually quite romantic i think he did
it on purpose uh let's just say i
definitely did it on purpose now twirl
me darling you got it sweet potato i
can't get away from you all right you
guys are adorable tell me everything the
doctor says about your uterine climate
oh and also that genevieve and i have
big news is this something other people
would keep private big time we're trying
to have a baby interesting yeah
something definitely doesn't add up
did you know there's a sausage you can
drink
what are you even talking about the case
oh we got distracted oh she has an
amazing tongue strong supple great bud
density okay i'm gonna take over the
question yeah i'm too close to this
disgusting eating habits hi genevieve
just gonna ask you a couple of questions
now and detective boyle will
just sit there and keep waving at you i
guess now then is there anybody you can
think of besides yourself that has
access to the gallery after hours no
just me and the vault is only accessible
through fingerprint id does charles have
a girlfriend i just saw her mouth my
name what did she say is she asking if
i'm circumcised what no who asks that
stop interrupting
sorry about that okay next question can
you think of anyone that might be trying
to set you up maybe an employee or a
rival of some kind maybe my ex-boyfriend
nick he's an artist a terrible one he
was always in debt and begging for money
that's why we broke up maybe he's
resentful dirtbag x oh that was my
theory remember teller was my theory
okay wait give me a second i want to
look smart when you say it okay
uh hey genevieve detective boyle wanted
me to let you know that he a college
graduate had a similar theory that it
could have been an ex-boyfriend wow he
is so smart
well it actually worked i gotta hand it
to you buddy whatever you're putting
down she is picking up oh good oh one
more thing
boyle has another question
tell when this is all over i'm gonna rub
her body in pate and then rub it off her
with a cornichon i'm just gonna give him
the phone back okay
hi
okay okay everybody just calm down and
take a deep breath
what the hell is going on man yeah what
the hell is going on you got a
girlfriend i know and she's fine
thanks sorry i was really planning on
you being in the cab during this okay
that wouldn't make it better maybe i'm
just i'm not over you yet and i would
have never said anything because i
thought you and jake were happy but
after seeing you at jazz brunch i think
i might have been wrong don't read into
that that was a freak argument we are
very happy amy we have all the same
interests we have so much chemistry when
we're together it's like no matter where
we are in san diego i feel compelled to
tell you that san diego's terrible i'll
lay it all on the line
amy santiago
will you marry me what okay really could
you stay in the cab i'm sorry i'll be
right there i promise or maybe i won't
what's your answer teddy i don't want to
be with you but you want to be with him
you guys have nothing in common oh yeah
tell that to william atherton the man we
both considered to be the second best
die-hard villain oh she meant it and
also yes we are different people but i
love that about us i love that jake's a
little messy and that he cares so much
about his dumb sneakers and he doesn't
get stressed out about calendars or
flossing my teeth no the non-flossing is
crazy copy that and i love you i'm just
so confused your fight was like
something out of a movie
teddy
i have to tell you the truth no amy is
dying she has one month to live marrying
her would be a waste of time
jake and i were only pretending to fight
so that we could destroy your phone
while we were on the stakeout and you
were in the bathroom we said you were
the most boring man in america and your
phone recorded it i'm sorry we didn't
want you to get mad at us and fail the
precinct wow
you guys are the worst you just proposed
in front of your girlfriend so potato
potato amy i loved you
all right i'm ready to go rachel should
we hit up the tenement museum no
oh it's just my former lover hello
sister ugh i hate when you say those
things back to
hello gina
it's daylight boyle why are we talking
this is an emergency i've been filming
my fitness routine with the precinct
camera to help improve my form that's
where i got these tree trunks
but i realized that i left the tape in
the camera and now it's gone who cares
who cares who cares
you
probably will
oh
well i love that you're trying to step
up your sex game but strength is not
your issue
stop humming and it does not turn me on
when you bend over and back up into me
did someone check out the camera this
morning yes hitchcock and if he sees it
he will tell everyone you need to get
that damn tight okay
he'll be all vulture i must insist that
you
desist i really think this is gonna work
also if you ever want to bust out that
whole impression at home i'd be okay
with that
oh
okay duly noted super disturbing but i'm
definitely gonna do it
you